you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
plastic waste problem pining up in
turkey we look at what's happening to
the uk's waste
[Applause]
my britons are being asked to get green
fingered in honour of the queen's
tribally
and we find out what it's like to live
and work in the antarctic
studying climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and coming up as britons are
once again allowed to jet off abroad
i'll be speaking to a sustainable travel
expert
about how to make your getaway more
eco-friendly
but first it's been revealed that
plastic waste exported from the uk to
turkey
is being dumped and burned according to
greenpeace
it's illegal to export plastic waste
from the uk
unless it's set to be recycled or
incinerated in an energy from waste
plant but investigators for the campaign
group
found supermarket packaging and plastic
bags by the roadside in
fields and spilling into waterways in 10
sites around adana province
in southern turkey now it's less than
100 kilometers from turkey's largest
port
a convenient stopping point for
container vessels
we're around 40 percent of the uk's
plastic waste exports were sent to
turkey
last year that's approximately 210
000 tons and it's a huge increase from
just
four years before when around 12 000
tons
were sent to the country the uk produces
more plastic waste per capita than
anywhere else in the world except the us
in 2018 we generated more than 5 million
tons of it that's enough to fill wembley
stadium
six times over but turkey's official
waste recovery rate
is the lowest of any oecd country just
12
in 2018 according to the country's
statistics institution
well the investigation by greenpeace
found waste including packaging from uk
supermarkets dumped across riverbanks by
the roadside
and on the coast and in many cases the
plastic was on fire
or had been burned to try to dispose of
it
with me now is sam chetten welsh
political campaigner at greenpeace
so what can the government do to ensure
that any plastic waste that's sent from
the uk to be recycled
actually is recycled and doesn't end up
burned like this
well thanks anna there's a huge amount
that the government can do actually
there's a very
active role they can play in sorting
this the first thing that they can do
uh you know the government has already
actually made a promise
to have a consultation on banning the
export of plastic waste but at the
moment their consultation
wouldn't include countries like turkey
and obviously that is where
we found so much of this waste turning
up being dumped and burned
but fundamentally the root cause of this
problem is that we are simply making and
using far too much plastic here in the
uk
and the government we believe has an
obligation to set targets so that
retailers reduce the amount of
single-use plastic that they use
and if we reduce single-use plastic by
50 by 2025
we can end the export of plastic waste
so we need to reduce the amount of
plastic waste that we generate but what
about recycling the government's
acknowledged the uk should and wants to
do more
of recycling in this country so what's
got to happen to allow that to increase
sure well i mean a big part of the
problem uh in terms of what we're
finding in those rubbish dumps that
you're looking at now on your screen
is a massive amount of incredibly mixed
plastic waste
that means plastic waste that you know
it is not really recyclable in any
reasonable in any reasonable way unlike
things like drinks bottles which you can
tend to recycle a fair few times but
ultimately recycling can only play a
very small specific role in this problem
because plastic as many people may not
know
is only fully recyclable about two or
three times before you can no longer
really use it
and that's why we're calling on the
government to reduce the amount of
plastic that we're using we have to
start with reduction first
that means switching to reuse and refill
you know
taking things back to the shop to be
refilled and those are the kind of
solutions that we need to see from the
government as
urgently sam chetten welsh thanks very
much indeed
thank you and we did ask the government
about their take on this and a
spokeswoman for the department for
environment food and rural affairs told
sky news
we are clear that the uk should handle
more of its waste at home
and that's why we're committed to
banning the export of plastic waste
to non-oecd countries and clamping down
on illegal waste
exports including to countries such as
turkey
through tougher controls well in today's
other climate news now the uk's
water sector will invest 2.8 billion
pounds in environmental projects
after the watchdog off-what put forward
a plan to lower pollution from utilities
the new projects will include
improvements in drinking water treatment
to reduce energy and chemical usage and
working with local partners to reduce
the risk of flooding
and protecting habitats
[Applause]
coral can evolve to save itself from
climate change according to new research
scientists have found that some corals
can swap out the algae that live
inside their tissue for different
strains that are more tolerant to warmer
temperatures
which could help them survive moderate
climate change
[Applause]
and there's a new big five of the
world's creatures but to shoot with a
camera
rather than shoot to kill it includes
elephants
polar bears gorillas tigers and lions
and was made by the new big five
initiative
that seeks to raise awareness of the
crisis facing the world's wildlife
the old big five the five toughest
animals in africa to hunt
were lions leopards rhinos elephants and
buffalo now the queen is no stranger to
a bit of local climate action having
planted an estimated 1500 trees
during her reign and now people across
the country are being asked to plant a
tree
for the jubilee sky's royal
correspondent rihanna mills reports
the prince has planted a young oak tree
specially flown to canada
from windsor park for decades all around
the world
it's been part of the royal day job the
queen
planting more than 1500 trees during her
reign
so it couldn't feel more fitting that
we're all being asked
to plant a tree for her platinum jubilee
it left me much to do
in windsor in march the prince of wales
watched by his mother
planted the first as patron of the
project
whether you are an individual hoping to
plant a single sapling in your garden
a school or community group planting a
tree everyone across the country
can get involved one of the founding
partners royal mail have planted trees
in every nation to kick-start the
project
but the rest of us are being asked to
wait until the next planting season
starting in october giving schools
villages businesses and
individuals the summer to plan the
woodland trust
giving away 3 million saplings to
support it on top of
expanding tree and woodland cover across
the country this is also a celebration
of ancient trees and ancient woodlands
the queen's green canopy will dedicate a
network of 70
ancient woodlands across the united
kingdom and identify
70 important ancient trees to mark the
jubilee
reanon mills sky news
from today britons are allowed to travel
abroad on a limited basis as coronavirus
restrictions are significantly scaled
back
it's great news for holiday makers and
airlines but it could be damaging for
the climate as global emissions creep
back up to pre-pandemic levels
so is it possible to go on a foreign
holiday and be climate friendly
well juliet kinsman sustainability
editor of the travel magazine conde nast
traveler joins me now welcome to you so
if you do want a
foreign holiday what are your tips to be
as green as possible on that trip
i mean i tend not to use the word
sustainable as much actually but think
about
positive impact so how can we go away
and think that our trip is
actually leaving uh good in the
destinations we visit well we have to
think more about the social and economic
factors
um flying is never going to be good for
the environment we need to make those
emissions
count i will say a little tip around
flying obviously always fly direct
because it's the taking off and the
landing part that
emits the most carbon so if you can just
fly direct that's really
it's really going to help but in terms
of where we go
and who we give our money to that is a
critical way to help particularly after
what we've gone through in the last year
to give you an example
in terms of booking a holiday thinking
about who you're giving your money to
choose independent local businesses
where the money stays in
local communities ideally that might
even be a business that's working
really hard to tackle the challenges
which are
behind the problems causing the the
climate emergency so
perhaps a lodge or a hotel that is
investing and protecting in
biodiversity is rewilding conservation
is at the heart of what they do
by having a holiday there we're
supporting supporting that uh
obviously great preservation but also
as i say the socio-economic side of
things uh if you look at africa
typically if you look at kenya had a
couple million uh visitors in 2019 to
their wildlife reserves
now that will have dropped 80 to 90
percent in 2020 which means
about a million and a half people will
have lost their jobs
that then puts pressure on their
wildlife areas in terms of illegal
logging in terms of
poaching in terms of bush meat pressures
so what we want to do is use that
holiday money
maybe we can't travel tomorrow to kenya
for example it's still on the red list
but we can invest in holidays that are
going to pay it forward
juliet kinsman thanks very much indeed
now in the latest in our series of
climate diaries we're hearing from
scientists from the british antarctic
survey whose work helps us better
understand how climate change is
affecting our planet
they're based at the rotherha research
station on adelaide island to the west
of the antarctic peninsula
where the sun never rises above the
horizon in winter and temperatures can
drop as low as minus 20 degrees
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather research station which is to
the west of the west
antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
so ryan how much wildlife have you seen
any whales
we have a resident pod of orca we see
the orca
on occasion once a week
[Music]
i really hope to build a more
comprehensive picture of what is
happening in antarctic ecosystems
over the season and also try and compare
this with past data
so we can untangle the effect of climate
change of what is just happening
naturally in such uh extreme environment
since 1997 we collect data
once a week during the winter periods
and twice a week during the summer
periods
so it's a long term time series to help
measure and understand how our oceans
are changing
there are definitely many many highs
living with your colleagues is a
fantastic experience
when we have finished the day we come
together with all the station that's
everyone that's working here and we
share meal time so it's a really great
communal time
also what's on our doorstep is is the
ramp so this is our local ski area
after a day in the office or a day maybe
if we haven't been out on the boat it's
definitely great
to get outside and and go for a ski so
we're really privileged to be here
well we've heard today how people are
being encouraged to plant a tree to mark
the queen's jubilee but
tomorrow we'll be hearing about a
project on a rather larger scale to
triple the rate of tree planting
across england we'll have all the
details here on the daily climate show
tomorrow see you then
[Music]
you